-The investigation
of President Trump's campaign
seems to be homing in
on several key figures
while also widening
to include more countries.
Meanwhile, Trump is spinning
a wild conspiracy theory
about the FBI spying on him.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-The president was holed up
in the White House
over the weekend
with no public events
while The New York Times
and other outlets
published one new bombshell
after another
about his campaign's ties
to foreign governments.
So naturally, Trump got up
bright and early Sunday morning
and unfurled one of his longest
and most incoherent
Twitter rants yet.
In fact, it would take too long
to have someone read
the whole thing for you.
So, as it goes, we're just gonna
have to speed it up.
Here it is.
[ Laughter ]
-And don't worry about
not being able to follow that.
It actually makes less sense
at normal speed.
[ Laughter ]
By the way, Twitter,
did I ever thank you
for raising the character limit?
I didn't? Good.
Also, it's not fair
that a president
who won't read a two-page
press briefing
makes us read a six-part
Twitter rant.
This rant is so long,
it technically qualifies
as a miniseries.
Look for it streaming
this summer on Net-dicks.
[ Laughter ]
Now...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...Trump is, in his usual way,
conflating and lying
about a whole bunch of issues.
And one of them is a story
published over the weekend
about his son, Don Jr.
Now, we already knew Don Jr.
held that infamous
Trump Tower meeting
where he met with Russians,
offering dirt on Hillary Clinton
during the 2016 campaign.
But what we found out
over the weekend
was that it wasn't just Russia.
The New York Times reports
that Don Jr. also met secretly
with...
Now, this story is crazy
for a variety of reasons.
For one thing,
it was arranged by...
So, Saudi Princes, Don Jr.,
and the Blackwater guy.
The only people missing
from that meeting
were Dr. Strangelove
and Monty Burns.
[ Laughter ]
Now, Prince was interviewed
by the House Intelligence
Committee last year
as part of their investigation.
And in his sworn testimony,
it really seems
like he straight up-lied
about his role
in the Trump campaign,
claiming he was just
a casual supporter.
Ugh.
Just when you think you know
every evil thing
about Erik Prince,
you find out
he's a yard-sign guy.
What did the yard sign say?
"Looking for a secret meeting?
Interested in world domination?
Call Erik Prince at 1-800-EVIL."
Now, let's just step back here
and consider
how many times Trump aides have
lied or contradicted themselves
in official testimony.
When it comes to meetings
with foreign governments
during the campaign,
just last week, the Senate
Judiciary Committee released
transcripts of its meeting
with Don Jr.
And here's one portion
of that testimony
where he changed his story
multiple times
in just a few sentences.
"I didn't know about it.
I knew about it after the fact.
I knew about it
when it happened."
Man, Trump nailed it
when he named this one.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Trump ]
He looks like someone
who can't keep
his stories straight.
Let's also call him Donald.
[ Normal voice ] And then --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Then there's the fact
that the official story
from the Trump camp
has always been
that Trump himself was unaware
of the meeting
with the Russians.
But then last week,
Trump's lawyer, Rudy Giuliani,
seemed to admit that he might
have been aware at the time
and just forgot about it.
Giuliani said...
What a comfort it must be
to have Rudy Giuliani
in your corner.
"Don't worry, boss.
I told them
that maybe you knew about it,
but you're too stupid
to remember.
You're welcome!"
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now...the other --
The other crazy part
of this latest story
about Don Jr.'s meeting
with Gulf states
is who else was in his office
when the group met.
Until now, there have been
a few Trump aides
who have managed
to keep their names
out of the special counsel's
investigation.
But The New York Times reports
that...
Ah, yes, top campaign aide
Stephen Miller.
[ Thunder cracks ]
[ Laughter ]
Although Miller wasn't actually
in the office for the meeting,
he was right outside in his
usual spot on the ledge.
[ Laughter and applause ]
So with Special Counsel
Robert Mueller's investigators
closing in on several
key Trump allies
and finding out more
about his campaign's ties
to other foreign governments,
Trump and his team
are doing everything they can
to obstruct the investigation.
And now Trump is spinning
a wild new conspiracy theory
about the FBI implanting
a spy in the Trump campaign,
and he wants the government
to look into it.
Trump tweeted on Sunday...
Well, I've heard Donald Trump
say a lot of things,
but I never thought one of those
things would be "hereby."
[ As Trump ] I hereby demand
an investigation,
albeit heretofore, unheard of,
nonetheless,
I demand one forthwith.
[ Normal voice ]
Now, the FBI
did have an informant
working with them,
but that's not a spy.
I mean, seriously.
You think they needed a spy
to catch you colluding
with Russia?
All they needed
was a microphone.
You literally looked
into the camera on TV and said,
"Russia, if you're listening."
[ Laughter ]
That's like
coming out of the bathroom
with white powder
under your nose and saying,
"I am ready to party because
I just did cocaine."
This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪